[Music]
thank you
it's the riffs are kind of hard though
yeah it's super hard some people start
to make music just like that no huh yeah
they say it's a very similar Limp
Biscuit [__] sucks
I forgot this is an anti-smoking podcast
see you guys later that just made me
like really sad
people say that Limp Biscuit yeah
[Laughter]
anyways yeah
Louie everybody
damn it smells like that it doesn't
smell like sex I should smell like
you see why I like hanging around them
yeah because they smell good they smell
sexy
she's like just like being around
cigarettes yeah
you you could you know what actually I'm
getting right now but
Vegas no no don't say it don't say it oh
sorry yeah sorry
there there which shall not be named um
because why we're not talking about
gambling yep yeah right yep
um you're no we're not talking we're not
talking not talking about it no not
talking about it nope nope don't even
start nope find another topic man it's
just I'm on The Tick Tock you know
yeah like I get a lot of these guys now
yeah who's your fave there's this really
creepy guy
his name's like J like it's like J
jackpot Dave or something like that and
you don't see him ever he just films
other people
and he'll just be like yeah yeah hit the
button hit the button yeah and I hit it
again I know you're talking hit it again
it's okay it's okay I hit it again it's
a girl he'll like do like
little 360 around them and like you know
move the camera down in weird ways and
be like who do we got here
and she's like like sorry that's just
like Monica
and he's like nice nice you ready to hit
a jackpot it feels like the beginning of
a porn
and then one of them is Ray J
yeah he's like we've got Ray J here and
Ray J is like it's very clearly like 4am
he's just not in a good state of mind at
all he's got face tattoos now that's
weird
Ray J does yeah
pull this up okay
maybe just Google it I know we we're not
talking about slots but this isn't slots
we're talking about this is this is uh
this is
unique human media yes search Ray J
Vegas slots jackpot
oh man I I hate seeing us I really hate
it too
yeah yeah I bet you do I bet you hate it
you gotta stare at our ugly mugs for
two and a half hours this really is a
it's just a sexy ass smells good in here
it really does
smells like a restaurant in North
Carolina in 2008.
the good old days good old days like it
used to be able to smoke in the whole
restaurant yeah and then they just had
smoking sections yeah like of everything
yeah and that eventually went away yeah
they ostracized yeah yeah Ray J has a
face tap this is him D lucky experience
now he's got like multiple dude look at
it
my left eye doesn't work so I can't even
tell if that's Ray J
right here we're gonna play the
lightning cash okay
for a thousand
where's yours
grab my card no like he's got one right
here and he's got like two but I don't
know like we play the slots every day we
live in The Encore that's definitely him
when I run into D lucky it's always a
good time because we always win so all
right here we go you ready hit the 125.
oh closer attack while I hit play
this is this is the contest
what do you think this is the 250. man
modern world is so interesting yeah you
know I just bumped into Ray J the slot
machine yeah I just put him on my Tick
Tock yeah yeah I know
he looks bad yeah can you Google when
Ray J got face tatts I have that's what
all the comments are like what when the
[__] when did that wild man maybe
he's just been living in secrecy and
then he got that he just said it I live
at The Encore so maybe he lives at the
encore
didn't he say that yeah he's like I live
in The Encore every day I literally live
right up here
that's scary man or you know maybe he's
doing good yeah maybe he's doing good
and he could be sober in this you know
could be Stone sober because you know
you just I'm very you know
you know I got a close connect that's uh
has figured out the slot machine game
yeah yeah right and I want to get into
it right right it's a very secret world
yeah you know it's a it's a total
underworld that you really you know you
gotta have the stomach for it yeah scary
place yeah but you know I got some
connects in there we're not talking
about it though nah I know some people
in that world yeah yeah
I know one guy's down like pretty good
19 500 500.
see the thing is like when
like
I I think you can assume if someone show
like someone shows up in a video playing
a slot
in Vegas they have face tattoos that you
haven't seen before you can probably
assume they're not doing too well yeah
or you could assume it's that dude
who uh was on our lawyers Channel
Spencer Cornelia yeah remember he met
the guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
guy's a character could be Mickey it
could be
he's getting them removed though no shot
yeah yeah yeah
what he's like getting them lasered off
yeah I've heard him say that a couple
times expensive is it it takes so long
yeah does it multiple sessions so many
sessions and apparently it hurts like
[__] hell it ain't it ain't
um
it ain't a quick one I kind of was I've
been thinking of doing it like on my
upper arm start over
but um like I would get it lasered off
to get it tatted again so I wouldn't
have to get it all the way off right
just enough where you could cover it
what do you want to get instead I just
like more something in this style just
something more I don't know what style
is that
just like traditional
American yeah
what would you remove
like the skull and the dice and
not the mom I would keep that but maybe
get it let me get it like go over it in
more black maybe or something I would
probably keep the flowers too
tattoos are sick but
I don't know I'd like to what the why
the [__] did you say like that I just
want to do it I just wanted you though
she's got a nude little body what yeah
because I got a nickel yeah yeah you you
do have a
cody getting riled up again
yeah perfect little [__] body
dude
we're not actually [__] it's fine
yeah that's true
you treat it like Voldemort man you
start even just articulating it you're
like no no no just hearing you say that
was a little bit much what in the voice
me being you being horny me you being me
being you
me being you being inside
laughs